foreign
[Applause]
welcome everybody
it's Drew's surprise birthday party
okay now Drew Drew has no idea what's in
store this whole show You're Gonna Keep
that blindfold on until I say take it
off right now okay okay how are you
feeling
I I feel so lucky I know
[Applause]
wait till you see what we have in store
for you we're about to welcome your very
first guest your surprise party but
first we need to get you into position
Drew okay so I'm gonna ask our team to
open those doors
[Applause]
walk with me
there's one and now I'm gonna help you
up a second one hold on
there
okay the skirt is beautiful but it was a
challenge on the stairs but it's worth
it okay now if you could do me a favor
and just walk this way with me and you
trust me right with my life and my
children understood come this way great
I'm gonna have you just turn around and
don't take that blindfold off but just
stay there for with me for one second
don't take it off okay this is the most
exciting blindfolded experience I've
ever had
laughs
yeah you do all right Drew um I have
this right here you guys all right so uh
Drew I'm gonna have you remove the
blindfold right now the chains really
[Applause]
everybody does know me well
all right so Drew you are of course in a
glass cage because we know that you love
a certain show
so we brought you to you and
come on out you
[Applause]
foreign
this is this is a birthday gift for you
I know that you like to remove stains
you're not supposed to want this
you know me so well yeah yeah and I I
have for you this is the key pen to this
to the lock I'm going to leave that with
you and I'm gonna let you two talk
foreign
how does this feel like I'm getting to
live every woman's fantasy I'm gonna I'm
gonna leave I gotta that dance you did
on Instagram you know how Casey and I
love you so much and that cute dance you
did the Meghan Trainor yeah Casey and I
texted afterwards and we were like oh
God he just keeps leveling up with the
moppy hair and your cute body moves all
we did was text about it you're just so
wonderful I can't believe
thank you
I mean
can you I I know this cage from the show
and Casey and I Casey Wilson wishing
that we could be the lucky women that
you lock up
um what what happens in here
um well I I mean I know certain people's
fate yeah I guess I was just curious as
to where this was going
I watched the show this is this is as
far as it goes here and we're gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna let you out whenever how
amazing would that be that would be
really epic talk about going viral if
you off to me in here I'm just saying
like it
now that would make some serious
television that's good content right
there yeah that is that that would that
would that would uh break the internet
yeah as they say all right Drew um how
are you feeling I just want to say thank
you to to Penn I cannot believe you're
here
and believe it or not we are just
getting started Drew's birthday surprise
continues Penn is here for the entire
half hour Drew and Ken brought you
another gift that one was clean the next
gift is a little bit dirty
[Music]